Hello Freak bitches.
And I feel like you guys,
I bought the chicken and stuff,
believe it at first I didn't believe it.
I'm like someone said,
well explain it to people who didn't hear our other podcasts and I'll tell me on
the finals,
well the match we're talking about,
and me and Joe talked about this and they made a Stewart Cooper made a film on
it,
but Oh Tavio Sousa.
His strategy was to not be honest back,
stay on top and just kind of maybe get a takedown late,
you know,
cause that's in that rule format or that points format in Abu Dhabi that that
happens.
A lot of people will just Russell and Russell and Russell and uh,
he wasn't engaging.
And crone is like,
like,
just like in saying,
he's like Marcello,
he's like,
he goes after it,
he's going to go 100% all he wants is the submission.
That's cronies,
especial grappler,
special fighter.
All he wants us is the submission.
And Oh,
Tevya wasn't really engaging.
And as a father,
no,
not as a fine as a coach.
I saw his coach as the fight progress.
The Guy St [inaudible] in Portuguese.
Okay man,
that's it.
That's all you want.
Okay,
keep going.
It's perfect.
Perfect.
And I see a guy just running from the fight and making strategy,
which kind of upset me completely.
I mean there's nothing perfect on that in my sense.
And but in these strategic aspect of his,
he's doing,
so I have to counter in somehow and then I start your make shoot,
tried to suggest the referee.
He was escaping.
He was try to avoid the fight because he's not positive points in the first 10
minutes,
but it's negative points.
So I,
I was hoping for a negative point with dot well fall.
This is stalling.
So,
and then I started to say,
Henry,
the guy start,
you're moving like,
you know,
he don't want to engage you.
It's just moving back like a chicken la,
la,
la.
And as the thing starts,
you're boiling.
I start to say,
hey man,
this guy like a chicken.
And the whole stage was this quiet.
Watching the fight is just this noise kind of overwhelming.
It's like throwing a chicken inside it in a for a Jujitsu competitor.
First of all.
I mean I know you're right here,
but I just have to be honest.
Everybody says you're the greatest ever.
You're the greatest Jujitsu competitor of all time.
So you are here the greatest Jujitsu representative all time.
Your son is competing.
This guy has to respect you and admire you and you're going bock,
bock,
bock.
And the whole crowd is listening to this.
I mean that's a lot of pressure on that guy to get into his head because it is
going,
because I was was suggesting the referee he needs should be punished.
Yeah.
And eventually like with 90 minutes or so,
he get minus points and that's what's exactly what generates him to say,
okay,
now I'm honeybee,
raw honey running behind.
So I have to make it happen and as talk and afterwards we've grown crone said,
dad,
when I do start,
you're talking like a chicken.
I felt like you want to explore them.
I don't want to make a mistake wasting the opportunity,
but I know he will come.
He so I was just ready for it.
So we kind of working together,
you know,
like the father and son Ward was perfect.
He shot right in and then he's already waiting for me.
Boom is over.
Go home.
Oh,
it's ice cream.
Isn't it weird how it like most cities it's always like the south side is the
bad side.
It's like whoa.
Really?
Yeah,
that's what's good.
What's the best area to live in?
North Tampa is where all the rednecks live.
That's where I grew up.
North Tampa,
Tampa,
elevated trucks.
Shit,
you got it.
Fireworks,
homemade fireworks,
fireworks,
hunting gators,
hunting gators.
When you were a kid.
Oh,
when I,
when we,
I'll never forget,
when we went to look at our land,
my dad bought like a piece of land in North Dakota in north Florida,
Tampa and he was like,
we're going to build on it.
We went out as a family to go look at it and there were these two rednecks that
had chased this other redneck in his underwear up on a mound in the middle of
the lake and they were shooting Bibi's Adam.
Mike is your land.
This is our land and my day and this is our lake.
And that land that,
that little mound,
I wish I had a picture cause it's still there.
I,
it's still there.
And they had chased the boy up there in his,
and he was in his underwear and my dad was like,
hey,
everybody cut it out.
That's enough in my,
they looked at my dad and they go,
we caught him fair and square.
And I was like,
oh my God,
this is private land.
It was like your land.
It was a lake.
There's a lake they were on,
they were on a boat.
So it was a lake and the,
and it was an island that was like maybe 10 feet off the shore of where our
house.
So it's a big lake.
It's a pretty big lake.
But yeah,
it's not all yours.
No,
the whole lake.
It's not all ours,
but uh,
but,
and then the other side of the lake was like North Tampa.
It was lutes,
it's called lutes.
We got in the car that day and then radio stations changed.
And I remember the song was downtown loop.
This is their intro to the song downtown.
Lutes kick off your boots,
give a Holler in a he hall.
And that was our new neighborhood.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
Why didn't your research it a little before you fucking bought land there?
No,
cause it was,
it was a cheap property.
It's like
childhood.
I fucking know.
Probably Hunt gators.
I think the whole state of Florida,
it's considered the south side of the United States.
That's a good point.
[inaudible]
matter.
Turning the Dick in the country.
So when you look at like losses like that and wins,
does that make you play more conservatively and upcoming events or do you just
have to play intelligently,
period and just take the losses when they come?
Um,
the place where you get more conservative is your bankroll management rather
than your play.
The play from one hand to the next is really about,
you have to put the magnitude of the numbers out of your head and try to make
the best play each time it's on you to make a decision.
So are you in the moment?
Are you zen or you still thinking about that $600,000 at you?
I'm pretty good at just getting myself into the moment.
Um,
the,
the place where you get more conservative is you lose for awhile.
You have less money than you did before that period started.
You reevaluate.
I have only 75% of the money I did a few months ago.
Should I maybe sell,
okay.
75% of my action in this upcoming tournament instead of 50.
Right.
I say,
I say that,
that that's the way in which you can get more conservative if you're going
through a losing stretch is play for lower stage.
What's the biggest losing stretch you've ever gone through?
MMM,
in dollar amount period.
Dar mounts.
Uh,
let's see.
I'll give you ever gone through like a couple million dollars in a weekend.
MMM.
In Games where I didn't,
where I had told action,
didn't have all of myself.
Yeah.
I've lost,
I guess my biggest losing couple of days was on the order of
50 million Hong Kong,
Hong Kong dollars,
which are bigger,
or let,
let,
let last rather.
So only like 6 million.
Oh my God,
son.
Only 6 million u s dollars.
And personally I had,
okay.